ومن امام قاعده مروى الجويه ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه من خلفك هذه القاعده
كيف تبدو الصوره هل هناك اشتباكات تدور في
هذه القاعده ام ان الامور تميل الى الهدوء
حتى اللحظه
نعم يعني قبل اقل من نصف ساعه من الان
كانت هنالك اشتباكات واستمعنا الى ذوي
القذائف والرصاص وربما المدفعيه اطلقت في
عمق ما تصل اليه الصوره الان الصوره الان
تمضي لتقترب اكثر من قاعده مروي العسكريه
هذه هي صوره لقاعده مروي العسكريه ولبرج
المراقبه لمركز العمليه الحربيه العسكريه
التي بدات منذ الامس قبل نصف ساعه من الان
كانت تتمدد في وسط هذه الصوره اعمده
الدخان كانت تتمدد بشكل كثيف ومباشر في
مكانين من داخل هذه القاعده ويبدو ان
وتيره الاشتباكات عادت من جديد بين قوات
الجيش قوات الجيش المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع يبدو ان المسار الان يمضي
نحو حسم هذه النقطه العالقه وجود قوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه تتمركز وسط
القاعده الى جانب احاطه قوات الجيش
السوداني
احاطت
السوار بالمعصم لهذه القاعده ومنع قوات
الدعم السريع من الخروج المعلومات ايضا
تشير الى ان كلا الجانبين الان ربما يسعى
لايجاد مزيد من الدعم
وحشد لقوات عسكريه سواء كان من قوات الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه او من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع لحسم هذه الجزئيه المتعلقه
بوجود قوات الدعم السريع داخل هذه القاعده
قاعده مروي العسكريه الان الترقب يسيطر
على المشهد الى اين ستمضي الامور الاوضاع
كلها الان مفتوحه على سيناريوهات متعدده
المواطنون يراقبون هذه هي مروي
بصورتها بوضعيتها الراهنه هاد هدات الامور
ولكن عادت مجددا قبل نصف الساعه الان
لنستمع الى صوت الاشتباكات لصوت الرصاص
وربما يتجدد خلال الدقائق المقبله ما هي
الاسلحه ربما من خلال يعني ما شاهدت ما
سمعت ما رصدت نزار التي تستخدم في هذه
الاشتباكات هل نتحدث عن اسلحه خفيفه ام
اسلحه ثقيله ومدفعيه وغيرها
هي نفس الاسلحه التي تم استخدامها يوم
الامس
اصوات رصاص لبنادق الكلاشنكوف وايضا الجيم
3 وهنالك ايضا اصوات للمدفعيه الثقيله
ربما اصوات لقاذفات الدبابات كل هذه
الاسلحه استمعنا اليها يوم الامس استمعنا
لاصواتها لدويها المناطق التي تحيط بهذه
القاعده اذا ما تجولت الكاميرا يسارا او
يعبينا هذه هي مدينه مروي التي
تغطيها اشجار النخيل هذه هي مدينه ملوي
بالبلاله الشماليه هذه المدينه التي اصبحت
الان نقطه اهتمام عالمي بحكم انها تتاخم
واحده من القواعد العسكريه الجويه في
السودان التي اصبحت مسرحا لعمليه حربيه
ابتدعت هنا في هذه المنطقه بشمال السودان
وانتقلت لتعم عدد من المدن والمقر
الرئاسيه لقوات الدعم السريع ووحدات الجيش
السوداني الاسلحه كما ذكرنا هي الاسلحه
التي تم استخدامها يوم الامس الاصوات التي
استمعنا اليها قبل قليل ليست بذات القوه
التي استمعنا اليها يوم الامس يبدو انها
اشتباكات متقطعه بين القوتين داخل مقر
القياده قياده القاعده الجويه وفي محيط
هذه القاعده حيث تتمركز قوات الجيش
السوداني هذا هو الوضع حتى اللحظه تمركز
لقوات الدعم السريع في القاعده احاط من
قبل الجيش السوداني لهذه القاعده لمنع
قوات الدعم السريع من الخروج هل لا زلت
اصوات الاشتباكات مسموعه حتى الان نزار
لا الان
انخفضت اعمده الدخان كما تلاحظون الان في
هذه الصور المباشره
هدا صوت الرصاص انا الان احاول ان استمع
لا اصوات رصاص بالفعل لا اصوات رصاص لا
اصوات لمدفعيه ثقيله فقط صمت يلي هذه
الضربات كنا في حاله الصمت قبل ربع ساعه
من الان بعدها مباشره استمعنا الى اصوات
الرصاص يبدو ان الامر سيمضي على هذه
الوتيره طيب
متبادل بين القوتين ومن ثم صمت وتعود
الامور كما كانت طيب يعني بالنظر الى الى
هذه القاعده يتبين المساحه الجغرافيه
الواسعه وربما الكبيره نزار هل استطاع
الجيش السوداني ان يغلق ويؤمن المداخل
والمخارج لهذه القاعده
بحسب ما رصدته انت بوجودك في مروي
نعم هذه القاعده كما ستوضح الصوره تبدا
كالاتي
محمد تبدا من من هذه النقطه في الاتجاه
الشمالي هي تقدر المساحه بنحو 18
كيلومتر مربع تمتد في هذه المنطقه او هذه
الناحيه الشماليه التي تغطيها الكاميرا ثم
تتمدد نحو اليمين تمتد هذه القاعده في
مساحه 18 هذه القاعده هي جزء من مطار مروي
الدولي هنالك مدرج وسط هذه القاعده يبلغ
طوله نحو 4 كيلومترات يستخدم في العمليات
الحربيه وفي العمليات العسكريه وفي عمليات
التدريب للقوات الجويه هذا المطار ايضا
شهد خلال الاشهر الماضيه والسنتين
الماضيتين شهد مناورات عسكريه وعمليات
حربيه مشتركه كتدريبات بين قوات الجيش
السوداني ممثله في القوات الجويه وقوات
الجو المصريه ايضا كانت هنالك تمارين
حربيه مشتركه بين الجيش السوداني ممثلا في
القوات الجويه والقوات البريه والقوات
الخاصه مع القوات السعوديه هذه القاعده هي
قاعده
عملياتيه اصبحت مسرحا لتدريبات ولعمل
مشترك مسلح واستراتيجي واملي بين الجيش
وبين نظرائه في المنطقه لذلك تنبح هذه
الاهميه لهذه القاعده الاستراتيجيه
العملياتيه التي انشات بعد العام 2010
عندما تم انشاء سد مروي الموجود في الجهه
الشماليه لهذه القاعده باعتباره ايضا من
السدود الاستراتيجيه لتوليد الكهرباء
الكهرومائيه هنا في السودان هذه هي
الوضعيه الاستراتيجيه لهذه القاعده اكتسبت
الان اهميه امنيه بعد ان اصبحت مسرح لعمل
عسكري بدا يوم الامس ويبدو انه سيستمر
طالما استمر وجود قوات الدعم السريع في
قلب هذه القاعده هل من جديد فيما يخص
القوات المصريه
المحتجزه داخل هذه القاعده نزار
المعلومات تؤكد ان القوات المصريه ما زالت
في مكانها القوه التي ظهرت يوم الامس على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ما زالت في
مكانها حتى الان ليس هنالك معلومات عن جسر
جوي خلال وجودنا لاكثر من يومين هنا في
مروي لم تحض على ارض المطار اي طائره
عسكريه او ناقل الجنود سواء كان من داخل
السودان او من خارج السودان لاجلاء
المصريين او القوه المصريه قوه الطيارين
الموجوده في هذه
القاعده هذا يعني انه ما زالوا داخل هذه
الارضيه ارضيه المطار والمعلومات ايضا
تتحدث عن وجود بعض الجنود والضبات
التابعين للجيش السوداني داخل هذه القاعده
عليه فان الامر كما ذكرنا مرارا وتكرارا
ملتبس الوضعيه الامنيه معقده داخل هذا
المطار وداخل القاعده وهذا ما يعسر ويصعب
امكانيه حسم الامور بسرعه في في هذه
المنطقه طيب هل هناك يعني معلومات عن قوات
اجنبيه غير سودانيه اخرى غير حتى القوات
المصريه الموجوده في هذه القاعده ام فقط
القوات المصريه بغرض التدريب موجوده في
هذه
نعم ليس هنالك من قوات
[موسيقى]
يعني حسب الجيش السوداني وحسب بيانات
رسميه للجيش فان وجود القوات المصريه لم
يكن بعد هذه الاشتباكات والعمليه وانما
كان وجود مستمر خلال الفتره الماضيه بفق
بروتوكول املي عسكري تم توقيعه في الخرطوم
وتم التوقيع عليه من قبل رئاستي الاركان
المشتركه في كل من السودان ومصر بالتالي
وجود هذه القوه المصريه بحسب الجيش
السوداني هو وجود ياتي وفق تنسيق وفق
ترتيب ووفق برتوكول مشترك ولا غير ان تاتي
قوات اخرى ما دام السودان ينسق ويؤمن
ويرتب معها